i'm scared to see him he doesn't seem
like the same person that i left when i
left ethiopia and i don't know what to
expect when i see him
that's not even my man and my heart
dropped
hi
benniam showed up in kenya after ari
told him this was his last chance to
save his family
and uh
he didn't save a thing in fact he dug a
deeper hole for himself and i feel sorry
for you and i feel sorry for ami because
i want ami to grow up and have a man
that's his father and he can respect
we're gonna talk about it plus we love
you we love you so much
jenny leaps into submits mom's arms
after they have an emotional
breakthrough she's telling me she loves
me and i was just like oh my god
it's just
i never thought i would hear it you and
everybody else jenny we'll get into what
led to some it's mom's change of heart
and if she's now allowing jenny and
submit to get married can schmidt and i
marry
do we have your blessings to marry
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia let's
jump into this binyam and ari saga that
continues to go downhill
help i've fallen and i can't get up
what's happening is almost as bad as
those commercials
after talking to benny i feel lost
because our relationship has
deteriorated completely following last
week's episode where ari confronted
binium about allegedly throwing parties
at their house and hanging out with
other women while she's been in the u.s
even today he doesn't want to pick up
the phone he continued to ignore her
calls but in ari's last attempt to try
to save their family she's following
through with her decision to go to kenya
with hopes that he will meet her there
so they can reconcile i don't even know
if he's really gonna come
and yes she says she doesn't know if
he's coming but she's still going
crazy
i decided that i wanted to go along
thank goodness for her mom janice though
she decided to tag along for emotional
support i hate flying
but on the other side of flying is
something good we hope right
yeah i hope so
honestly i feel so hopeless about the
whole situation
but i promised him that i would not keep
him from avi so i'm going to keep that
promise all right once they landed in
mombasa they headed to the apartment
already rented which wait let's talk
about that for a second
ari left comfortable new jersey took a
long
fill in the blank flight to kenya
we've been flying for over 24 hours with
a baby
and during the car ride she revealed
she's paying three months rent for the
apartment they're staying in does he
know how to get to where we're staying i
send him the address i don't care if
kenya is cheap and i don't care if it's
her money or her parents money this
woman is going above and beyond to
protect binyam's heart from being broken
again when he's not even prioritizing
hers
i just don't know why he did this to us
honestly this has been one of the most
trying times of my life
i feel
so brokenhearted
[Music]
say what you want about ari but it takes
a special person to still look out for
you after you hurt them fast forward to
that evening when ari and her mom are
settled in at the apartment and binyam
knocks at the door
oh i wonder who that is
do you think it's binny
check
it could be daddy
oh my god
oh my god
hi kazuhu
no she's not okay binium they didn't
even hug but he did bring some sort of
gift for her in a box
oh let me get up so you guys could sit
together hello
how are you opinion because
if you've ever been cheated on before
it happens
better not happen again though or even
if you just suspected that someone
cheated on you you know that coming face
to face for the first time with that
person after the incident is one of the
weirdest feelings ever
there's this nuisance of anxiety that
you've never felt around them you're
rehearsing everything in your mind that
you want to say shoot a part of you
wants to look good and ari made sure she
did that
but the biggest thing is you go in with
hope that they say or do something that
would at least help mend your broken
heart which rarely ends up happening in
this case was no different it's so weird
to see benny like playing with avi like
everything is normal and then
remembering everything that he's just
put me through over these past two
months this is the same guy that
wouldn't answer the phone for us and was
taking pictures with random girls at our
house yeah although bingham's been
acting funny he was extremely happy to
see his son
he also said that he didn't expect ari
to be so distant which makes it seem as
if he doesn't see the way he behaved as
a big deal vinny and i both arrived in
kenya yesterday
and our first night together was like
sleeping next to a stranger after they
woke up the next day it was time for the
talk
y'all ari went and found an interpreter
so she can make sure she and bingham
communicate effectively you know
sometimes we don't understand each other
very well ari she can understand me like
we have good conversation
i don't know why she's
bringing the translation because there
is no time for you to be understanding
only what you want to understand binion
that's why
you
stopped calling
and you stopped texting at the top of
the combo ari brought up the fact that
bingham stopped calling while she was in
the u.s and he either wouldn't pick up
his phone or he would turn it off
because i don't want to fight just when
you come down you can talk to me but
what about if you never pick up the
phone how would you know if i'm angry
and when i text you i love you baby i
miss you and you there's no answer and
then ari brought up the other women and
this is the part that got me and i could
be looking into it too hard but when she
started to explain how people were
calling her telling her binyan was at
the club and hanging out with other
women
he cracked a smile and ari didn't catch
it i don't know how she didn't catch it
but i did vinnie he's at the club vinnie
he's seen with with different women
vinnie he has different people in and
out of the house all of the time look
look at that smirk
what's funny binion people have seen you
with one or two particular women again
and again
that is what people are saying it's no
you're wrong well if you didn't cheat
binyum say something that makes it make
sense you're just gonna say no you're
wrong it's no you're wrong okay
what else me in the freezer we opened
like studio and then we're working out
there if you have a studio in there so
many people they come in and they say
we're working there binium the work
excuse is not working
come on now admit you had a few parties
you didn't do that much work when she
was there
or did the pain of her leaving inspire
you to get in the booth
any new love songs
[Music]
you're wrong we need an album on the way
based off how much you've been working
anyway he says he didn't cheat on ari
but clearly binium is someone you have
to ask
well
what do you consider cheating and ari
did that so in this past two months
you've made no mistakes
for me
yeah i know you don't mind you thinking
justin
with other people i didn't what have you
done to disrespect your family i i don't
want
i don't want to fight but something i
don't want i came for fixing for my
relationship having honest conversations
like this is part of fixing your
relationship minion
you can tell he just didn't get it i'm
thinking he thought getting back on
ari's good side would be easier but she
says until he can own up to his behavior
she will never be in a romantic
relationship with him again i guess that
means they broke up i know where you're
at and i feel really sorry for your baby
i know your story and it's so sad
and i feel sorry for you and i feel
sorry for ami because i want ami to grow
up and have a man that's his father and
he can respect
i'm very very sorry for you
and the life that you are gonna have i
feel sorry for your situation this
situation is sad
one if someone has a pattern in the past
of being unfaithful
you have to take note of that and two
something i've had to learn the hard way
you have to show people how they can and
cannot treat you
which means making the hard choice to
put up those boundaries like ari did
even if deep down you don't want to oh
binyan we gotta get it together bro come
on no more self sabotage
you ready
almost just putting the mascara on and
then i'll be ready all right moving on
to a more joyful moment as we know
summit's parents have been staying with
him and jenny for a few days smith's mom
specifically is there to teach jenny how
to be a good indian daughter-in-law but
in all actuality she's been wanting her
to fail so she can prove once again why
she and submit should not get married
it's been a long
a long time coming to my surprise a
change
has come people the change that took
place was sparked by the astrologer who
came to the house for a visit and y'all
know sumit's family hangs on to his
every word so this could have gone
really bad for jenny which she was
somewhat anticipating the last time we
went and saw the astrologer he told us
you have to wait you can't get married
right now but shockingly the astrologer
ended up telling smith's mom about
herself and her behavior in gyoria
opinion
he basically told her what submitted
jenny do with their relationship is none
of her business what's meant to be will
be he went on to say that she's coming
off as a selfish mother and if she keeps
going this way she will be viewed as the
enemy incognito
i don't know what's being said
jenny i'm gonna need you to take some
more classes okay because that's always
the case i don't know what's being said
the astrologer finished off with this
message this is god's wish
think it this way
he added that if submits mom continues
with her meddling her health will be
affected very soon the next day summit's
parents pulled jenny aside for a heart
to heart that's when smith's mom told
her that they will be going back to
their home the quote
is
then came the l word which after so much
hate i don't know if it was genuine or
not but it was sweet so i hope so we
think our glove should maintain
this is this is
listen
no jenny no
we love you we love you so much
[Music]
smith's mom said she can change for her
son
wow
it really hurt my self-esteem hearing
all the horrible things that smith's mom
was saying about me all of these years
and now here we are
and she's telling me she loves me and i
was just like oh my god
wow
that astrologer has a lot of power in
his hands when it comes to this family
it's kind of scary now if you're
wondering if submits parents are going
to allow him and jenny to get married
here's what they have to say
they call me
marriage
cleveland
we are not going to stop you i'm not
going to support you i understand while
all of that sounds good submits mom told
the straight to camera shot that she
hopes her letting submit go will cause
him to back out of getting married
so
baby steps i guess
later on in the episode jenny won an
estimate if he's ready to tie the knot
and to her disappointment he said he's
not in a rush you want to go get married
tomorrow or
i want to get married
but not like okay tomorrow let's just
get married tomorrow
how soon
i don't know like it's maybe
i don't know that wasn't assistant
that's it
we'll get married
okay because then it starts to sound
like excuses and i don't
want to hear any excuses
yeah i know well while that's up in the
air so is ari and binium's future next
week mama janice sits down to talk with
benny her apartment was turned into this
crazy place with all these girls coming
in and out
absolutely it's not like that
let's talk about reality
did you cheat on
janice i think you are the last person
he would admit that to but she probably
would be able to tell if he's lying
though she definitely has that emotional
intelligence
alright 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with et because we are covering it
all i will see you next time
you